most of us think of Saudi Arabia as the
oil Kingdom they're one of the most
dominant voices in the industry and they
profit hundreds of billions of dollars
every single year from pumping out oil
but something that many of us Overlook
is that Saudi Arabia is also the Islamic
Kingdom Saudi Arabia is home to Mecca
which is said to be the holiest of
Islamic cities the founder of Islam
Muhammad the prophet was not only born
in Mecca but this is also where he had
his Revelations way back in the early
7th Century given this religious
significance I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that most Muslims try
to pilgrimage to this holy city at least
once in their lifetimes this is what
leads to an influx of millions of
pilgrims to the country on an annual
basis for the longest time the only way
you could even get into Saudi Arabia was
to either be a pilgrim or to have a work
visa it wasn't till September of 2019
that Saudi Arabia started accepting
tourists but even today Mecca has
restricted to only Muslims and trying to
sneak in like Iraq is taking extremely
seriously hearing all this you would
think that Saudi Arabia would also be
super keen on protecting the city's
cultural and the architectural history
but this is actually not the case in
fact Saudi Arabia has been actively
destroying Mecca's architecture for
decades since 1985 Saudi Arabia has
destroyed 98 of their historical and
religious sites the vast majority of
which was in Mecca if this number was 5
or 10 you may be able to argue that
there's no agenda but at 98 there's
clearly something going on here one
researcher puts it as it's as if they
wanted to wipe out history and it ends
not like they're always building new
religious sites on top of these ruins
either more times than not they're
building hotels Resorts and sometimes
it's a lot worse for example they
destroy the house of the prophet's first
wife in order to build public toilets I
mean at this point they're just being
insulting so why in the world is Saudi
Arabia destroying their cultural
heritage
taking a look back the destruction of
Mecca is not a new phenomenon by any
means in fact it has been an ongoing
trend for nearly a thousand years dating
as far back as 1205. while it's been a
long time since then the reasoning
behind current destruction is not that
different it all comes down to the
beliefs of one sector of Islam called
wahhabism wahhabism is the prevailing
form of Islam across Saudi Arabia and
they're not fans of worshiping people
visiting the shrines and tombs of even
prophets and Saints is heavily frowned
upon it's thought that visiting such
places will result in Islam's gravest
Senate which is to worship anyone other
than God this does make sense to a
degree if millions of people visit the
homes and tombs of religious figures
it's only natural that some of them
start to see these religious figures as
God themselves but while that is a risk
it does seem rather harsh to wipe out
centuries worth of Heritage just to
prevent a few from quote unquote going
out of line the way that Saudi Arabia
justifies this is by building structures
that support their view of Islam just
because Saudi Arabia has been destroying
most of Mecca does not mean that they're
looking to destroy all of Mecca when it
comes to sites that they believe are
truly pure and holy like the Kaaba they
not only protect it but they try their
best to enhance it over the years Saudi
Arabia has poured tens of billions of
dollars into the Kaaba and the buildings
that surround it a perfect example of
this is the Glorious clock tower that
they built right next to the Grand
Mosque of Mecca not only does the clock
tower look magnificent but it has
extraordinary capacity the main tower
itself has over 16 million square feet
of floor area and contains 1 618 rooms
hearing this I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that it cost 15
billion dollars to construct and this is
just one of their many Hajj related
projects they've built several top of
the line hotels parking garages
restaurants and everything else that you
might need to have a positive pilgrimage
they've also spent a substantial time
and resources trying to expand the area
that surrounds the Kaaba this way more
people can visit on an annual basis the
most recent Expansion Project was
completed in 2018 which brought the
total size of the great mosque to 187
Acres capable of supporting 2.5 million
worshipers as you can see the Saudi
royal family is by no means anti-islam
if anything there are actually massive
supporters but the key thing to note is
that they only support their view of
Islam historically they had no issues
just blatantly raiding and destroying
people of different sectors but in
modern times Saudi Arabia's approach to
the situation has become more
sophisticated they're not destroying
these cultural sites just to destroy
them they're destroying them so that
they can build structures that support
wahhabi Islam by Framing it like this
the Saudis have been able to shift Focus
away from their destruction of Heritage
and move it over to their construction
of Heritage and this framing has allowed
them to continue their destruction out
with a substantially less backlash
while the Saudi family likes to
perpetuate that their destruction is
driven by pure and holy religious
reasons only there is little doubt that
keeping power likely also plays a role
in their decisions Saudi Arabia is an
absolute monarchy meaning that they
still have Kings and princes and these
are the guys that rule over the country
they don't have an elected prime
minister or president or anything along
those lines in fact they virtually never
have elections power over the country is
slowly passed down within the royal
family alone history has taught us that
such monarchy that are almost always
overthrown by rebellions and Wars but
Saudi Arabia has actually had a pretty
successful history with the monarchy now
this isn't to say that Saudi Arabia has
been perfect they've had a rather Shady
history when it comes to Human Rights
and women's rights but neither of these
have been enough to spark rebellions
within the country and the key reason
for this is that the kingdom has given
its people the 3Gs God gold and Glory in
terms of God it's clear that they're
supporting the prevailing form of Islam
within the kingdom wahhabism to the
maximum extent most Muslims within the
kingdom are either neutral regarding
this issue or they actually support the
destruction one user commented this is
good we don't worship decorated Graves
this proves it most of the Muslims that
are unhappy with the destruction are
located outside the Kingdom so they
don't present that much of a threat to
this Saudi family's power in terms of
gold Saudi Arabia has literally stacked
their reserves with nearly half a
trillion dollars worth of gold and cash
they also have extremely lenient
Taxation and Welfare policies when it
comes to Saudi Nationals in fact Saudi
Arabia has no personal income tax so
most Saudi Nationals have no complaints
when it comes to the economy and finally
in terms of Glory Saudi Arabia is
literally the most prominent Islamic
country in the world both religiously
and economically when Saudi citizens are
getting God golden and Gloria they have
very little reason to Rebel or question
the power of the Saudi family but
imagine for a second if Saudi Arabia did
not destroy these historical buildings
Not only would they not be appeasing the
Hobbies within the country but they
would simultaneously be creating an
opportunity for non-wahabi beliefs to
grow and prosper within the kingdom this
is clearly not something that they want
given that they try to discredit
historical sites with every opportunity
that they get for example Muhammad the
prophet's apparent birthplace is
surrounded by signs in four languages
that tell visitors that there is no
proof that Muhammad was actually born
there if this Saudis didn't do this
they'd just be asking for non-hobby
sectors to grow it which would not only
create tension between this group and
the government but also between this
group and the rest of Saudi Arabia so it
would essentially be cultivating a
rebellion or a civil war you'll see
people questioning the power of the
Saudi family and you'll probably see
some religious figure rise up and lead
the Revolution and based on history
religion-based conflict is usually the
most dangerous form of conflict given
that both sides have unbreakable beliefs
I don't know about you but I don't think
the Saudi royal family wants to end up
like the Iranian Shah so they likely
won't be stopping the destruction at any
time soon
while the Saudis policy of Destruction
has played out decently well within
Saudi Arabia itself the same cannot be
said about its non-wahabi Muslims to
many of them Saudi Arabia's actions lack
even the basics of decency in the modern
world just because you don't agree with
another person's religion it does not
mean that you get to go destroy their
history and even if these sites aren't
wholly like the saudius claimant they're
at the very least important to their own
history and culture the saudi's decision
to destroy these sites despite this
connection has come off as extremism to
many the common belief amongst these
people is that the Saudi family's ego is
way too high and that they're putting
control on profits over history and
culture after all it's not like they had
to destroy these sites to even build
their hotels in the first place there's
plenty of space on the outskirts of
Mecca where insane hotels and resorts
could have been built instead it's not
just non-wahabi Muslims that are upset
with Saudi Arabia's actions either
historians and archaeologists are also
not a fan of this Behavior either these
historical sites likely would have given
more context as to how people survived
on the peninsula for the past several
Millennia for historians this is not
just a matter of protecting Islamic
history but a matter of human history
many historians and activists have been
posting pictures of Islamic historical
sites on social media to try to raise
awareness surrounding the situation but
this hasn't really done all that much
because no one is going to speak out
against Saudi Arabia Muslim countries
that don't want Saudi Arabia to reduce
their Hajj pilgrimage quotas meanwhile
Western countries that don't want to
jeopardize their source of oil one of
the only exceptions to this is the
former president of religious Affairs of
turkey mehmed Gomez he told the Saudi
minister of the Hajj that the skyscraper
overshadowing the kabad destroys history
but honestly I don't think this Audis
really cared about his thoughts so while
resentment is building outside the king
this probably won't be leading to any
sort of change anytime soon
in the end the destruction of much of
Mecca is truly quite a shame whether
these places are holy or not they're
important piece of human history that
should be studied and appreciated but
instead the Saudis have been slowly
destroying the city for hundreds of
years and this has especially
accelerated within the past few decades
they've Justified their destruction by
claiming that these sites lead to sins
and that they're not in line with the
wahhabi way but while they don't admit
it it seems like keeping control and
power also plays a major role in this
decision while this has angered many
Muslims and non-muslims alike they're
simply not much that anyone can do about
it after all it's not like the Saudis
are going over to Egypt and destroying
their pyramids the Saudis are simply
destroying their own buildings so you
can't do much more than just give them
another perspective whether they
continue the destruction or not is
completely up to them did you realize
that Saudi Arabia was destroying their
own history comment that down below also
drop a like if you hope that decides
rest in peace and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions and
logically answered until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]